[Music]
when you report
fake news which cnn does a lot you are
the enemy of the people cnn should be
ashamed of itself
having you working for them
it's like in a state of shock i'm not
thinking about that that's okay i know
you're not thinking you never do
i'm sorry what a stupid question that is
what a stupid question
but i watch you a lot you ask a lot of
stupid questions
i want to have that fight with you hey
all right another fight with me
it's okay in the meantime i'm president
and you're not
[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
oh that's um did anyone get it right by
the way the uh the intro what it's
inspired by no i was just thinking about
it
oh i don't tell anyone you through that
question it was marie saleh was a
frenchman
and then go over and see all the birds
and the trees very well known
yeah even though i don't think she ever
saw a farm in her life she was a chain
smoking french lady who likely engaged
in all sorts of acts of degeneracy as
the french dukes
speaking of which we will be talking
about cuties today we're going to be
talking about the
lancaster riots which you know you would
surprise like how can anyone
cover them yeah it's terrible if they
have cameras they shouldn't have
anything to plug them in
no amish country joke and uh we have
uh also the lapd the knees been defunded
we'll be talking about that and we'll be
teaching the hodge twins brazilian jiu
jitsu
how are you half asian bill richmond
he's glad to be here yeah you still on
no caffeine yeah
do you feel it uh creeping up on you now
i mean i feel other things they're all
negative
bunch of negative feelings that's my
life he had a good weekend
i had to get prepped for this cuties
show of course i'm freaking out that's
true
barely legal coming up how are you
gerald a i'm doing well good uh button
up that top button uh quarterback
garrett is here hey good morning and
audio weight okay so we have some things
to get
let me ask you this first off do you
think we're going to be seeing more
riots
uh or cop ambushes specifically we've
gone from riots in general
now to cop ambushes like you've seen in
los angeles and this is nothing new you
know this happened
in los angeles after rodney king and my
uh grandfather actually was in the air
force he was a colonel in the air force
and would run reconnaissance
uh with snipers in the rooftops during
the detroit oh wow
riots don't expect john boyega to teach
you about that in that
motel film the destroyer
covered no and black uh police officers
had to ride home and unmarked cars with
protection in the detroit right
my dad watched the tanks go down kaju
road sitting on a mailbox he was short
late bloomer so i want to know if you
expect to see
more of this and i want to see really
quickly before we move into the
lancaster
uh protests see what they're covering on
cnn
and what is that pfizer ceo and my
company declined funding for vaccine
research yeah
oh i'll tell you that really quickly the
reason they're declining federal funding
for the vaccine researchers so they can
be uh
independent and provide it hopefully uh
more soon without you accusing donald
trump of politicizing
trump's dude just like hickenlooper
accused donald trump i believe it was
taken looper one of those second-rate
dnc candidates accused
donald trump of politicizing the
wildfires while saying
the only way i quote the only one the
only hope we have of putting out these
wildfires
is voting joe biden i do enjoy how you
can switch between different sites and
they'll go from
donald trump sends billions to vaccine
research
funds cronies in the pharma industry and
then you go like to the next page and
it's like
donald trump refuses to support pharma
and hard-working
pharmacy science accelerates vaccine
trials
by cutting through red tape oh i'm
confused
you should be brian stelter's straight i
told you
i'm more confused yet yes very it's our
job
speaking of confusion uh lancaster
pennsylvania
uh okay so this was it was lancaster
pennsylvania you want to make sure that
i'm correct right
but uh um amish folks are i used to
perform i performed in lancaster
pennsylvania wow early on one of the
first shows that i had ever done really
uh on this country huh was italian villa
east
and i was left there by my ride i was
opening for him oh no
yep i shouldn't use a horse jeff norris
was his name he left me in
pennsylvania and a waitress from
applebee's had to drive me
to the bus stop so that's nice of her
her name was fallon
i hand a guy nice hand to god i mean you
know you're in a bad spot when it's in
applebee's waitress who has to rescue
you
all right i guess so in the realm of
actors i'm a four in the realm of uh
touring stand-up comedians who appear in
lancaster pennsylvania
i'm a nine so getting a lift wasn't too
hard
just turned on the old crowder charm
which was please
please this guy this hack left me here
there's nothing here
i'm going to starve except an applebee's
uh okay so uh
these were the rioters the protesters in
lancaster i want to show you them first
they were upset of course after a police
officer
shot a man and uh we always know that
that of course is racism
here's what they had to say about it we
need results
and at this point these young people
here are gonna get it one way or another
look at that white guy wow why is the
youngest son from home improvement
banging on the back of that
horse trailer that's where he is we
always wondered where he went
so this is of course the narrative and
this of course sets off riots like i
said 71
send me one video one video of a
completely just
cut and dry lynching like we're talking
about that's the narrative right now i
haven't seen one i've seen cops
act poorly i've seen cops have bad
training i've never seen a clear-cut
situation
in the last six months i shouldn't say
never but recently with all these riots
you know this is the new season of riots
i haven't seen anything even close to
what you guys claim let's go to the one
here so you know what happened the guy's
name was ricardo munoz a woman was
fleeing the house and he was chasing her
with a knife this cup is a hero but just
like by the way with jacob blake where
we don't care about the fact that the
woman was sexually assaulted had a
restraining order an act of warrant and
then said hey by the way the
guy who sexually assaulted me he's back
here the cops said thank you for doing
the right thing we'll be there to
protect you
in this case a woman is being chased by
a man with a knife
but uh let's forget about me too the
officer's not supposed to do anything
here's the body cam foot get back
and the man is chasing with a knife now
let's go
we'll see a freeze frame here hold it ah
he's not only holding a knife he's
making a war face
that's like daniel day lewis and last of
the mohicans
he definitely looks serious he's in the
air it's an action move
and we have riots in protests and expect
by the way this to be brushed under the
rug
just like rachard brooks that kind of
went away because they thought well you
know what the american public is gonna
be on board with us because all he did
was aim a gun at a cops face beat the
crap out of them
and it wasn't a real gun it was a taser
then americans said i think beating the
crap out of an officer
and aiming a taser at his face is enough
and they said you know let's forget
about that one here's jacob blake and
once people say you know what i think a
restraining order for a would-be rapist
on going back to the house stealing the
keys of the woman then he allegedly
raped anything they'll go you know
that's fine
hear about this one they'll go you know
what the guy was chasing a knife
screaming like xenia the warrior
princess going
i think okay here's and they'll bring
you another one just it just keeps
happening i love that they released the
body cam video because they're like oh
you guys have a problem with this this
is like what two days later
or very very soon after here you go
here's the video yeah just see it yeah
i think that's what they're looking for
that's what they're supposed
we won't have any more visitors go and
see where we shot witness out here so we
need to release this footage to protect
these historic landmarks in lancaster
you know and that's what's
incredible that they're in the call for
justice they're actually making sure
that justice is not done so instead of
actually doing investigations they're
doing it the wrong way now i know you
know the way that we approach these
especially on the show
is we talk a lot about how these
officers are and how they're showing it
but what's really interesting is that
these officers every single one of them
even in the most justified
homicides these officers are traumatized
they don't want to shoot anyone yeah
that's the last one they want to send
these videos out
they want to respect the family if that
guy had
family brother sister children they
would normally not release that they
would go out there and try and talk to
the family first and then over the
course of time
it would get out but now they're being
forced to stop riots
by showing the video did you know last
night there were reports that those
rioters who were out
started to get the body cam and they
were like oh
yeah and some of them were starting to
like some of them were like i gotta walk
away why didn't you send in a social
worker
he's a product of the system it was just
a deep fake right
yeah really well i didn't know that we
needed to learn this lesson again but
the lesson from this
don't don't chase the police officer
with the knife well yeah should be i
mean that should be the lesson at the
end of the day
uh but i guess the lesson from the left
is that women of color don't need
protecting and we should lengthen the
police response times
and as long as the man is of color if
you are a woman of color
take the raping and shut up yeah well
rock beat scissors so maybe maybe use a
rock
oh by the way speaking of scissors this
guy munoz had a history of being
particularly
stabby he uh stabbed four people in 2019
including a teenager
now this is where people say why are you
bringing that up that's not relevant
it is relevant it is relevant because
this is a call right a distress call
because it's not the same as some random
pull over how many times have we found
out that there's a distress call and
they go by the way this is a guy
uh kind of his calling card is like they
call him the stabby bandit
and the cops are like oh my god it's a
savvy bandit well i better be prepared
and we don't take that into context
stabbed four people including a teenager
esther and also at a certain point can
we admit that people like jacob blake
that people like munoz here meaning
people who commit these crimes i'm
talking about protecting their victims
who are also people of color before you
start your you people [ __ ]
can we admit that people who repeatedly
commit violent crimes and flagrantly
disregard arrest warrants restraining
orders
that there needs to be something done
and it needs to be forceful if we can
all agree
that some kid with a baggie of weed
shouldn't spend years behind bars can we
all agree
that someone who has a history of serial
violence should probably
never be out in a way uh that doesn't
mark them so everyone knows that they're
a threat to society i don't know what
you do at this point yeah
he served his time put his dad four
people served some time came out step
more people serve some more time
i think i'd like to know before i start
hiring him to buy groceries
[Applause]
well it's really hard to get the knife
out of my spleen so you know we both
have things we gotta deal with prick
well you should bear the burden stephen
of his choices and the police officer i
don't know if you saw the video he was
walking up to the house very calm
you know everything was like he
understood he had a scene that he was
going to to make sure people were okay
but
he wasn't like guns drawn going in like
if this guy had shown up at the door
holding the knife just standing there
he'd been like sir drop the
knife drop the knife this would have
ended totally differently than running
out like
trying to go after somebody like freddy
krueger yeah well freddy krueger has
claws for hands so that's a horrible
film reference it would have accepted
mike
they're sharp or jason they're sharp
jerk the unauthorized
lorena by the way
uh if you're watching this on the
youtube of course do subscribe to
uh android and apple there are audio
versions uh available where you can
download
anywhere leave us a review and uh listen
for the secret word
and uh we'll tell you how to come back
and play that game and get a lot of
gerald's hair
okay thank you uh so we have this of
course happening we're about to get to
the lapd
situation which was an ambush against
police officers was that the sheriff's
or the pd i think it was the sheriff's
it was a sheriff i think it was the uh
last sure
the lasd i apologize los angeles
uh no no the lapd they were shot last
week right this is the weekend
so many it's hard let's just call them
all racist pricks including the black
ones
well right any officer wearing the blue
i don't care if you i don't care if it's
justified you're a little timothy
elephant it doesn't matter you're a
racist
and we want no part of you speaking of
which we're going to defund you by 150
million which is what
they did in los angeles uh and uh that
also brings us to um
oh yeah the latest installment here a e
a lot of people were mad
uh and your pressure your uh sort of
boycott uh forced them to uh bring back
not the the old iteration of cops but
the new iteration so agreement um we
have a preview here of uh amy's new
series no cops
tonight on no cops
hmm
it's not as compelling there's no third
act i know yeah that's true
you always told me about the article you
gotta have the story arc you know
take it up a e at least with the cops
there was an act you know there was a
there was a there was a middle and there
was a there was a third there was a
climax but this just sort of happens
well that that sound will help him as
he's dying like it's a very calming
sound the phone rings
i
i do appreciate the realism though right
i mean it was very very accurate
yeah yeah everyone you know every
episode is a cliffhanger of knowledge
is very much a cliffhanger until you
read the police report yeah
0.2 seconds in how long does it take to
bleed out from a stabbing with no 9-1-1
answer
uh the report says about nine minutes oh
well
at least you're listening for nine
minutes it's you know it's all about
like they say it's all about the
cross-platform
promotion with no cops they want to send
people to the website
to read the police report so it sends
them back in and they sign up for the
mailing list
it's a no cops ponzi scheme is what it
is um
let's go to the la so it's not lapd it's
la sheriff's stuff
i'm pretty sure it's the sheriff's
department yeah okay uh la officers
let's go with two
los angeles officers um we're ambushed i
believe we have a b-roll
here by a gunman watch walks right up
shoots them runs away that is a short
guy too it looks like a kid looks like
the
guy from willow that's not the worst
thing you could say i mean he didn't
even
even have to aim down you know you shoot
a lot like yeah
you have to aim down in a window right
right you have to get like probably
two little rascals yeah just it was
buckwheat one and a half little rascals
[Laughter]
so um then after this
what happened was uh you had black lives
matter protesters
uh who were trying to go visit they
claim they wanted to go visit
who they refer to as the murderers the
officers in the hospital
uh with some of them yelling uh we hope
you die here you go here's a clip
now here's the thing you can go to
reddit politics or huffpo and i'm saying
only one person said that
well here's the deal nowhere else
outside of a black lives matter ant of a
protest would one person say
we hope you die mother effort is someone
who is right exactly
an attempted assassination with other
people going
clearly everybody's central roast yeah
and there was at least one other person
who wanted him to die the guy with a gun
right at least
we don't want to jump the gun too so we
can't ascribe motive
that's true i'm sorry that's my fault
very confused thought it was a shooting
range they didn't oh my gosh
this is why you got to follow the rules
range is hot range is not hot enough
otherwise you'll
shoot too often and these
it is unreal what is this right now
let's go to cnn really quickly gop
battle battles for votes in crucial
pennsylvania county hey is there
something else going on in pennsylvania
cnn maybe hasn't been mentioned at all i
haven't seen anything
this morning i looked i've seen
hickenlooper go up there and say our
only
chance to put out these wildfires is to
elect
joe biden i don't know how about you
stop the arsonists who lit some of the
fires
and allow us to burn away some of the
brush which she can't burn away some of
the vegetation controlled burns like we
used to take this environment
build some dam so you can actually have
access to water that's a start by the
way are we gonna blame
record crop yields and record lake high
levels on donald trump for climate
change ask governor whitmer about
climate change
son of a all right um
you're doing good and this is just so
you know they were saying they were like
we want to go
visit those murderers well you can't
like this is a public hospital
first off i don't think you know how it
works second you really don't understand
rules work because my wife was paralyzed
they wouldn't let me go visit her
because my mother happened to be the one
who dropped her off
right do you know how i ended up
visiting her i have a french canadian
mother who gets stuff done
she does have i told you this story my
wife was there with the
you know she uh she had the gbs with
doctor we didn't know what's going on
she was paralyzed from the waist down
and so i'm finished doing the show i go
in to visit my wife and uh i say hey i'm
here to see my wife they say oh yeah
sorry 24 hours you can't and i said oh
yeah well i'm going to
so they said no no you can't i said okay
so i went and i sat down i texted my
wife i said listen
they're saying that i can't visit you i
don't care if i end up on the nightly
news
i'm going to get in there but how long
do you think you're going to be here
because i'm only going to get in there
once
[Laughter]
and she goes she says well just hold on
hold on i'm going to have your mom talk
to them i swear to you i wait five
minutes
the doors swing open a man in a surgeon
mask comes out
i just see behind him for a fraction of
a second my mother standing like this
tapping her foot
if you know my french canadian mom yeah
i see him and he goes
that your mom i said yeah he goes
[Laughter]
my mom just read she just argued and
she's just foreign enough
that there was like all right i don't
know we're open but can you believe this
these guys they said we want to go visit
the systemically racist
murderers um are you next of kin yes
i am the most nextest of kids
you don't show up saying those things to
get in the door yeah
maybe not being dressed like that and
waving a flag and saying i hope you die
uh but may we go in and see them please
i wonder what the plan was when
once they got in there yeah i am
listening as is
emergency contact as you will see
next of kin person i am his wife
[Laughter]
don't question
the saddest part about that is that
actually at some point if you don't have
definitions of gender or
race or anything else to be able to
describe people anyone could walk in and
go
no that's my that's that's totally my
husband right oh yeah
okay never mind all right if i don't
have to show id to vote i definitely
want to show to go see my
wife right yeah okay i'm just going to
go in why are you carrying a bowling
ball with a candle in it
it's religious i'm sorry seek dagger and
what have you
go on insert thank you
you guys have a light i'm gonna yeah
this this is like a protester or
somebody
i mean just use a protester right
somebody doing a protest and they get
shot and it's like every like donald
trump supporter showing up at the
hospital or anybody that's a donald
trump supporter showing up and saying
yeah i hope they die too it's like
why they didn't do anything they were
just sitting there you can say that
police officers or whatever officers are
involved in this
are murderers and that they're all
racist but cops that were literally
sitting in their car
doing nothing at the time that haven't
been accused of being the people that
shot somebody in a racist torrent
right like that's what i'm saying
they're a part of the system
that's not true they're a part of the
listen listen listen all right listen
listen all right listen listen listen
listen listen they're part of that
oh okay see i thought you were gonna go
you but i thought you were gonna weave
in your body that's funny sometimes
people say like
why don't you show all the change of
mind but sometimes we should just
release like the very few that we
haven't released
and it's just that you were born on that
fence right yeah
or like some guy sits in that repetition
business card is running for local
congress like those are the only
everything that's useful we include yeah
yeah
but you're part of system even some even
we were stretching with the covid one
because
some of the arguments were totally
irrational yeah um
most of the left are i don't know if you
guys go go back and watch that there was
a girl very nice she sat down and she
was talking about cove and she was out
there
in dallas doing all everything acting
like it wasn't really a threat when i
told her about the numbers how they were
inflated she goes
oh my god now you're making me terrified
to go with it i said well hold on but
i'm telling you it's actually not as bad
as she's like
but they're still covered though oh
yeah some people you just can't go
that's when we didn't include yeah no we
didn't
um by the way donald trump did did i
already tell people hit the notification
bell oh you don't
notification hit the notification bell
if you're subscribed on youtube every
morning at
10 a.m monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern 9 a.m central
this tuesday we're gonna be doing the
donald trump town hall oh yeah and uh
we'll toss to you guys do you want us to
as well
do the thursday town hall i know that
not everyone here will be available for
thursday town hall i
it came up so quickly uh i don't really
know what the town hall with joe biden
is going to be it's going to be one big
glorified ad for depends
a lot of teleprompter communication
going every time they pan to the ground
they're like
dry wow literally every month it's a
running commercial it's amazing
they go to the ground it just shows this
is the leading pad and then they show
joe biden with that little blue dot
i think he's a walking he's so democrat
he pees blue
no sir that's antifreeze stopped
it smells sweet that might do him some
good at this point
uh okay so donald trump responded to
this animals that must be hit
hard we have his tweet if they die fast
trial
death uh penalty for the killer only way
to stop this so
it seems like donald trump has been
pretty clear on the ambush of the
officers
and this is what when people say oh both
parties are the same no they're not at
all
joe biden's response weapons of war have
no place in our community
we need to ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
okay joseph dude let me be clear here
he used a handgun and it's in california
where you already can't
have high-capacity magazines this is the
whole point
by the way criminals who invade your
home they often statistically
travel in packs they roam in backs or a
school if you will
or a gaggle and so a six-round wheel gun
isn't going to get it done look at the
reason that cops carry high-capacity
magazines because of the miami shootout
where they were outgunned by gang
members who just were using
semi-automatics
and they kept reloading their magazines
reloading their magazines so criminals
often being multiple people at once if
you're someone with a limited capacity
weapon it's going to be a problem but
handguns can be used as you see here
with an ambush on cops
this is the most illogical argument and
shows you
transparently the immediate pivot the
immediate pivot to gun control
we need to ban assault weapons you
didn't use an assault weapon we need to
ban high-capacity magazines already in
california the shooting happened
i pooped and by the way this
is a pesky little thing that criminals
tend not to obey laws anyway yeah
somehow
you know do anything also uh los angeles
cut funding by 150 million dollars do
they expect better results they expect
better they don't work out for them as
we all do you know
you're gonna have to crack a few eggs in
this case kill
sheriffs i'm serious these people
you know what why do these lives not
matter at this point of course
and also shouldn't that did have
bulletproof glass do they all have
bullet proof
i thought their windows were down i
don't know oh were they down
that's too expensive we need to reduce
the funding and have them go out in the
kit car
yeah exactly yeah i don't think there's
i think most police vehicles the side
windows are not bulletproof one there's
the angle
two the how thick it can be on the side
and work in the
mechanisms yeah yeah i don't think and
after the budget's cut they're going to
get golf carts
yeah well and instead of like armor you
know you know
proof that whatever yeah exactly they're
going to get like they're going to get
the cardboard i think
it's going to be spray painted like
those scooters yeah
hope hope you can get away which i will
say probably the most bold people i can
think of are the uh um
the the motorcycle cops when i was in
los angeles she was a kawasaki someone
called me it was a motorcycle i think it
was the kawasaki 1100
and i was just sitting there going man
if i'm some kind of a gang member
doesn't want to get pulled over
and like tink
yeah yeah problem solved yeah so those
guys were incredible
uh drivers they had to re-up from what i
understood re-up their driver's license
re-up their testing
and uh can you imagine being a
high-speed chase as a police officer on
a motorcycle like going 90 down the 405.
that's kind of badass
you know compare it with those bicycle
policies look on chips they did just
fine
okay that's true yeah he can move his
hair they did well the glasses those
were the i think the key element
uh anyway let me know what you think i
think this is an absolute tragedy and of
course people have been emboldened to
shoot officers so we've just gone
through two very clear examples
yeah where officers had their lives in
danger and here's i'm not just talking
about
is the shooting justified or not or is
some kind of a punishment justified
talking about
why don't we care about the lives of
these people yeah yeah i thought after
the dallas shooting we'd go ah you know
what they have a tough job
it is amazing just like when you call
trump supporters nazis and it makes it
okay to shoot them execute them
right or just punch them in the face
right everyone's a nazi when you say
that police officers all police officers
are part
of an inherently racist white
supremacist
systemic racist system it makes it
justifiable to commit all these we're
seeing
the fruits of it we are seeing people
justify actions that americans would
have thought completely unfathomable so
if you actually buy this idea that your
only hope to stop climate change is to
vote joe biden well guess what your only
hope
to try and put an end to this
lawlessness is to vote for the guy who's
actually
called it out yeah exactly and basically
they're going to turn this guy
into a martyr and i just want to tell
you like cnn i've been watching all
morning
zero zero mentions of this so far zero
zero mentions right now we're talking
about the nfl teams honoring george
floyd there you go
right now by blowing a giant horn i
wonder how many yeah apparently it was a
wiser loser from a dr
seuss book how many how many
how many people who work there work
security there how many police officers
there do you think have been in this
situation
you almost didn't come home that night
do you think any of those nfl players
walk up to them and go hey man
thanks i get that i have a multi-million
dollar contract and i go out there i get
all the the glory but i wouldn't be able
to do this safely if not for you
actually guarding people from the stands
preventing from walking on not just to
mention naked streakers which is kind of
gross
but people who could want to you know
live in my basement like stalkers from
david letterman thank you officers how
often do you think they give them a pat
in the back and appreciate it because i
tell you what
we do it all the time all the time when
we have any security goes out there
and even when we had police officers who
refused to show up when we were in uh
illinois
uh to be paid overtime because of the
union issue there when we did a private
security show up we said thank you we
wouldn't be able to do this without you
exactly if you're going out there and
taking a stand for george floyd
how about you just start thanking a cop
because guess what
not only do they often not get to go
home at night and i don't just mean dead
they might end up in the icu
but they also know that even if they
take the actions necessary to protect
the would-be rape victim and themselves
from a man screaming with a knife like
he's in
the revenant yeah that they're gonna be
on the nightly news unless the body cam
footage is released right away and their
reputation is ruined for years to come
so thank a cop every now and then thank
the good cops we always say they're bad
cops they're a good cops
thank a good cop if someone pulls you
over you're giving a speeding ticket
don't give them a hard time say hey
thank you for being cordial and take
your ticket
go on your merry way all right we have
to actually uh do a live read here for
black rifle coffee even brendan get your
ass in here we're gonna be reading your
chat also
uh for mug club exclusive atlanta dot
com slash club after this where is
brendan
all right brendan come on in let's have
a black rifle coffee
black rifle uh the promo code of course
is crowder at uh a lot of
at blackrafflecoffee.com crowder this is
green coffee did you bring
yeah let's use that okay okay okay black
rifle coffee
you see you seem nervous brendan uh why
would i be nervous yeah no one's gonna
hurt you brendan
that was a one-time thing i mean
microphone overreacting uh
company is continually committed to
supporting
them no we're fine law enforcement and
first responder causes with the
company's buy bag give a bag campaign
that's great we're just getting gold
make sure to give the gift of america's
coffee to um deployed troops around the
globe
okay that's enough give me the kids did
you go to play it again that sounds like
a great program
a lot of apparatus going on those pads
reek i want you out of my studio no
one's going to shoot you today brendan
today for crying out loud also that's
the worst
face protection you could have it is the
absolute worst yeah it's almost low
you're just throwing it hides the bb
into it yeah like one of those little
maze toys you get the cracker jack's box
like it would just
guide the baby into his eye yeah uh a
lot of credit dot com slash
mug club black rifle coffee dot com
crowd or promo code
is crowded you get twenty dollars off
brandon off twenty twenty percent
i was confused by the goalie pads he
doesn't know what he's talking about he
doesn't know
anything he's just distracted he doesn't
drink coffee because he's from a rural
area of wisconsin where he would drive
two hours for a chick-fil-a
i feel sorry for no stupid that's
actually i don't feel sorry for him he
made his bed
and i think i'm pretty sure he had those
goalie pads on the wrong legs
he should know he's up there uh patrick
hua he is not
okay speaking of joe biden are we all
gonna be talking about
this is just really cuties the guy who
doesn't know anything about gun laws uh
also is being busted recently been been
busted multiple times for using a
teleprompter
um which you know listen you do have to
be prepared and you take any edge you
can get when you're going into the
hard-hitting territory
of james corden
[Laughter]
this guy over the stairs yeah
where's the proctor with the lesser from
cats
the guy from the carpool karaoke yeah
he's going to single-handedly put out
the fires
i tell you what i have always and i used
to get crap from conservatives jon
stewart i always thought was funny
stephen colbert was really funny doing
his character
uh bill maher had some kind of funny
stuff of course i always thought david
letterman jimmy kimmel they can be funny
but the new breed the trevor noah
samantha bee
and james corden i honestly like it
almost seems
like when you when people were uh they
were self they were self
uh uh i'm trying to think comedians who
sucked who didn't believe in themselves
they would try and find the crappiest
opener and you could see it like i would
try and find the best opener i possibly
could
openers ended up being a last comic
standing those you would find
comics who get a crappy opener because
they just don't want
anyone to see i feel like that's what
the networks are doing with trevor noah
and james corden they're going let's get
a mediocre middler
so that they can just become a puppet
and say whatever we want them to say
they can't come in and ask for too much
money which we don't have anymore
because no one's watching our shows
it's the only explanation i can have for
someone who is
fat uneducated and unfunny but still
joe biden had to not prepare but have
his prompter at the ready
we have videographic evidence here it is
for so long i have so many
incredible incredible incredible
pictures including one here that may be
too heavy to lift up
but this is one of my favorite pictures
it's a picture of me
and my two boys when they were in heist
when they were in college
which one's the one having sex with the
other's wife okay oh there it is
so many things wrong with us keep that
up there one of those sons is having sex
with the other son's wife i believe
and why would that picture be too heavy
to pick up
unless it's made of solid brass slash
mercury i have no idea
and not only is he dumb enough to
require a prompter
he's dumb enough to not realize the
basic concept of reflection
yeah and it's totally fine if he just
has a monitor there so that he can see
himself and he can see who he's talking
to but there were words and there was
highlighting going down
progress he looks around forever and he
pulls out a massive
pose like a big giant yeah i thought he
was looking for a photo and like maybe
he was like under his papers or
something
like that
it's like joe everybody thinks you're
weak so when you lift this this picture
make sure you say how heavy it is
first that it's almost impossible for a
normal man to lift it like this
carefree right down and then we're gonna
pan and have a carnival barker who gets
his weight saying my that old man is fit
as a fiddle
exactly it's gonna work this is gonna
work really well it's gonna improve the
eyebrows where everyone thinks that
you're a demented old
pinch circus monkey so uh
here's and here's the thing this isn't
this isn't a lone incident people need
to understand this and this is a i
seriously have a problem for this i
don't know if right now we can do a
reflection
there's nothing on prompter right there
you can see i'll show you right here i
just have
clips so i know exactly which clip i'm
going to yes there is no prompter and i
have no problem with people who use
prompter i've had to use it sometimes if
i have an interview and bills like my
half asian lawyers like make sure you
don't get this wrong so i go
what is the statute of
uh but i'm concerned when this man is
running for president yeah
and it's a continual problem here's
another clip of him with the prompter
and uh and in addition look at his hand
watch
we have to make sure
the president must use the defense
production act yeah that's that's
unfortunate let me go to the second
thing
oh is that because the first thing has
already gone up it's like it's like
mario
he scrolled he also doesn't understand
that he can scroll back
the world no longer exists it's gone
oh look look if you're giving a speech
and you want to have a prompter like you
said you want to have a couple of key
dates and facts written down so that
you're accurate on what you say that's
fine
but when people are asking you questions
oh it's even worse let me show the next
clip and then we'll
talk about it more here's another clip
where when people are already asking
pre-written questions
yes which really the reason you do that
is so you don't need a prompter you know
yeah
you know what i don't want to be caught
using a prompter so i'm going to script
the question
uh and joe vine's like how about we do
both like well for you
that's yeah yeah that's prudence yes
probably here's a clip and i would like
to know
what will your administration do to help
them give them that chance
she's reading thank you move it up here
i need my answers given to me oh no i
was just watching the jeffersons and i
have it stuck in my head
you're moving on
oh gosh and this is what really bothers
me i have always said this that you will
never see him debate donald trump on
stage and i said you know what maybe
with a zoom call
why because he can have his prompter and
you know what that is an
unfair handicap given to joe biden
because you can level any criticism that
you want against donald trump most
most of them many of them are valid not
from the leftist media but i mean from
conservatives out there who actually
have some valid criticisms
but not being able to go off book or be
on his feet is not one of them the
problem that people have is like why
won't he just stick to the script
whereas joe biden has showcased that he
is completely incapable
of doing it without a script so if they
do any kind of a debate this would be a
huge advantage again to try and tip the
scale so that biden seems like
anything other than the demented old
pants pooping circus monkey that he is
yeah
yeah well even when he had two brain
cells to rub together he would he was
like they were like don't go off script
because he might say something racist or
insane
[Music]
which he did frequently in 2008 and 2012
whenever they were you know going into
office i don't know why we expect
anything different and seriously like a
pre-recorded question
uh you have every opportunity to go
through this and go
that girl asked a question about this
here are my three or four things that i
want to hit
go through it and the the thing you do
when it comes is like
okay go ahead and scroll up guys so i
know what to say get on up here come on
move it on up you move it up what i say
to move it up and i'm saying the move
prompter up
we're live no i don't use i'm telling
them that i i just told them to shut off
prompter because i don't need it
i don't want it i don't love it all
right well can you answer the question
it's just i will if they go to the next
thing
right yeah exactly i feel like we're
gonna get to a point where it's like
hello my name is joe
biden joe biden yeah i'm running for
it's sad my life it of course it is why
are none of his family members saying i
mean that's what you're busy collecting
money for
oil companies and having sex with each
other's wives yes that i guess they just
can't say hey dad
you know what maybe time to pack it in
yeah anyway you need to get a when he
can't nurse
yeah he can't even vamp and say like
thank you so much for your question you
know really
this is an important issue like that
kind of waiting for something to change
just say like you know okay look i'll
give you just some
you just take from option uh column a
column b column c any one feed me a
political question and i will give you a
non-answer answer
that joe biden could do ask me anything
i'm joe biden
what was the score of the cowboys game
last night well you know what i
appreciate you uh taking the time to ask
the question
in these turbulent times and people like
you the working class are the backbone
of america
and while i don't know the score to that
game and then bridge to whatever it is
he can't bridge to anything
because in his mind it's a bridge to
nowhere the real time the bridge too far
every time you know what becomes very
concerning is what is he going to do in
an international summit
what is he going to do when he's in a
room with a leader who is 20 or 30 years
his junior
and 50 years more mentally capable than
him sniffer then poop
uh yeah maybe i mean that's like that's
a great like you know with donald trump
right one of the criticisms is that
when he gets off script he gets real pro
america right yeah
which oh gosh that's terrible yeah he
gets a little harsh you know maybe he
gets a little insulting
uh but ultimately what's our issue here
but then when you have a joe biden where
he's just going yeah that sounds great
yeah no no no here here look look i got
this briefcase
it's it's attached to me i don't know
what it's for
you want it you want it i don't know
what's in it they say it's important but
you you could just have it yeah i don't
know what's that just hold this for me i
don't know hold on a second it makes it
keeps making a
ticking sound after i punch in these
numbers
they told me one two three four was
something i could easily remember
but then somebody calls me in russian
what are you talking about joe biden i'm
a little distracted by these [ __ ] in my
pants
it's a little squishy right now you know
what should have happened i mean really
we're not
we don't want to be home yeah no we
don't want to be talking about this
right now what the democrats should have
done in the primaries is somebody should
have said hey
stop this guy cannot do this job we are
going to put him out there
and he is going to fall apart in front
of people they should have done the
humane thing and said joe this is just
your your time is done just move on and
it would have been fine but now you've
put him out in front of the world and
said he's completely competent
and that forces us to show you day in
and day out that he's not the humane
thing would be to put him next to
uh uh brown and rich scott rich
in the deep freezer all right let's uh
move on
the wall right there let's move on to
speaking of uh uh
whatever cuties nice segway
we talked about it last week but oh my
god when people talk about this country
turning into a land of degenerates and
we're going to after this take your chat
and show the hodge twins by the way uh
jiu jitsu a whole segment
for mug club members only um
i was okay i have covered crappy media
for a very long time but seldom am i at
a loss for words
and uh let's first show to set this up
you know brian stelter has always argued
here's my problem with stelter and cuomo
and
even tapper i don't have a problem with
rachel maddow i have to reiterate this
because sometimes people don't
understand they go why don't you go
after a matter of or oh donald here's
why
i almost said chris o'donnell from
batman i mean you could go after both
lawrence o'donnell is the hammering guy
it's a crime all in other words
fling with alicia silverstone what
happened to her i don't know
don't answer um
oh sorry i thought something was
relevant on cnn it's not because i want
to avoid the riots and ambush of the
what's about the big ten i'm good brian
stelter chris cuomo these guys they
still maintain that they are journalists
they say we are going after the facts
and we will
call the powerful to the mat and we will
speak to the issues that matter
we are unbiased we are truthful that is
why they bother me so much because here
is something
child pornography one could argue is a
layup
it should be like if there's one thing
you should be anti that both the left
and the right
okay child pornography would be at the
top of that list
especially when you consider the fact
that brian stelter has
openly talked about here's a montage of
how objective and truthful this program
is
i tell you what we are only a truth
emergency right now
of course news outlets make mistakes of
course politicians make mistakes
the dividing line is between those who
seek the truth
and try to avoid mistakes and try to
learn from them
in us versus those who don't give a
rat's arse
about the truth oh and don't cop to
mistakes and they just lie their way
through life
so what's the role of the press in this
broken environment
in part our role is to keep collecting
facts all of the facts
so that citizens can make up their own
minds but i think it's also our role to
stand up for
decency and morality really especially
if others
won't decency and morality wouldn't 11
year old
tits qualify uh mr selter i know not
really an 11 year olds but just you know
she's supposed to be so pedophiles at
home on netflix
creates the illusion like my thumb right
like that only with an 11 year old's
tits it's not real but it's meant to be
titillating for pedophiles so
this is what's interesting last week our
number one
segment was on cuties yeah as a matter
of fact everyone copied our title where
we said cuties it was a big story it's
worse than you thought and it was the
same title everywhere else um
which i don't care about i'm glad though
that the word is getting out about
cuties
and just how awful it truly is
i wasn't able to watch all of it because
i don't feel that i need to
at this point and i'm a big believer in
in portraying reality so that people
know what they're talking about but at a
certain point it's like listen
there's nothing there's no argument that
makes it acceptable to
even show simulated sexual undulating
from nine to eleven-year-olds it's just
morally reprehensible but it was the
biggest story anywhere it was so big as
a matter of fact that we have um josh
hawley tom cotton
jim banks and uh ted cruz in a letter to
the
attorney general bill barr asking them
to investigate so there's a call right
now to investigate whether netflix its
executives or filmmakers
violated any federal laws against
production and distribution of child
pornography
now here's what was amazing i watched
all day sunday all morning
sunday cnn brian stelter did an
interview with the founder and ceo
of netflix he just talked we just showed
you it's our job to gather the facts
to let the citizens make the there was
not one question
about cuties can you think of any other
story
from netflix recently nothing what
hillary swanks away she hasn't she
hasn't been relevant should she taped
her titties down to play a boy
[Applause]
[Music]
the old boys don't cry titles wonder
give her an oscar since then nobody
cares
so the point is cuties is the story from
netflix
and brian stelter asked nothing his
argument was well you know what it was
pre-taped well guess what cuties was a
story
still even a few days ago a week earlier
he should at that point because before
it had been released he could have said
you know what people are really worried
about this release of cuties because the
number one trends for weeks were hey
this could be a violation of child
pornography
right the poster came out instead he
didn't ask but even worse than that is
poppy harlow who is very fetching i will
give her that uh did an interview
uh the next day i guess after the
pre-tip she didn't interview she didn't
ask about cuties
so two interviews from cnn the bastion
of truth
facts first is their slogan not a single
question about the show that has
actually spurred
demands for an investigation into child
pornography distribution
and violation of laws and their stocks
just plummeted like
or not and we'll ask bill where he can
explain where he can explain to us
where he lines up enough viewers think
it's an issue yeah
and keep in mind this is the same time
that uh governor gavin newman just
signed a bill into law where um
they lowered sex penalties for uh sex
offenders with uh
who abuse minors so this is california
like we said slippery slope
there's no more slope anymore it's look
behind you the slope was slippery and
now it's eroded
it's gone it's completely i think it's
just a cliff at this point just straight
down
no there's no more cliff now the cliff
it's moved down like in tremors
so okay so this is i want to know where
you guys line up because i don't want to
send i try and avoid sensationalizing
cuties made me sick to my stomach to
watch it that's why we had
brendan and bryce twerk for you because
i was like i can't show it no no you
can't do that and i saw it unfortunately
some of those
you watched the whole thing no no no no
some of the some people were sending out
clips initially yeah and then they were
like this is a bad idea to send out
clips which was
absolutely right don't say that i told
you not to let joe biden dm you
it was anthony weiner yeah um so so
couple things one
so without question like looking at the
content of the movie and the description
of it and the way that it's been
portrayed is without question we've
crossed a moral line and so then you get
to the question of the legal line right
right um and so a couple points first of
all
a lot of folks are like well you know i
looking for child
porn law and i can't find a law that
says child porn that's because
it's more accurately described in the
word they actually use is csam
child sexual abuse material because
any act of filming a child in any of
these types of situation
is an act of abuse and circulating that
material
is another form of child sexual abuse so
i actually appreciate that that word is
used because there could be pornography
that is legal and there's all child
pornography over that term it's not a
it's not a legal term but however that
term is used definitely bad right the
reason we use this specific term is
because it's bad and because
it's also broader than just pornography
that would be absolutely it gives us
more protection of minors as opposed to
for example with pornography if there's
no consent obviously that's illegal if
there's an abuse of other laws but
you're saying with this
it's broad enough that any depiction of
a sexual
activity well and the whole point is
because a child cannot consent right
because of the idea that well hormone
blockers but that's another day yeah
we're all right i mean we could just
change their entire biological makeup
it's totally fine but you know
but separate and apart from the the the
definition of the word csam it's the
question
of you know people often ask and
actually the nick mc which is the
national center for endangered missing
and endangered children
you know they often get questioned
federal authorities get a question like
oh man like my parents took a
photo of me when i was like in the
bathtub or like as a very young kid
right right
and so there's one set of categories of
when you're actually engaged in sexual
acts no questions
very you know always bad no no question
at all then there's this question of how
do you have a test that decides
when material is uh lascivious enough is
usually the word used in most state and
in the federal statutes
to decide is this depiction intended
to be sexual is it intended to be erotic
is intended
i would think cheeky shorts and sports
bras with girls rubbing their groin
would
suffice but that's opinion and that's
why and that's why when you look at the
context and how it's presented
that's really where the main problem
regardless of whether it actually
crosses the legal threshold of child
pornography
or csam in those particular issues is
the question of
is this the kind of thing that we are
encouraging children to engage in sexual
materials
now i know what the the rebuttals have
been right the rebuttals have been well
it's actually a critique of that
it's actually saying we don't think that
these young women should be doing it
so we showed a bunch of it oh but don't
worry the parents were horrified when
they watched it
uh something you know okay uh but you
know we should be casting call
yeah well literally this is like during
the actual films
but but a point quarter black made this
point earlier before the show is
remember you mentioned this in the very
first uh show on on cuties when you
when you said 650 and the director said
oh she was 651 right what where's the
film
of the 650. i mean people who auditioned
of the people who auditioned yeah
where are all the back films of all
these different folks yeah how do you
audition for this
yeah do they just sit you down and go
like what are your measurements
and she goes um i don't know i wear
uh small from kid get like she's noel
mcpherson
i mean slap it a couple times though
right right yeah exactly can you please
twerk so you think that
do you think i don't think this is
political grandstanding it seems like
there's enough there to
at least have some kind of an
investigation absolutely i think the
investigation is warranted
i don't think that they you know in the
face of the
initial questions it shouldn't have been
oh it's fine it's art
it should have been let us demonstrate
exactly how
we took every step possible to prevent
this even coming close
yeah to the line of being and i tell you
what i'm really worried when we talk
about slippery slope
it's obviously a arnold schwarzenegger i
don't know if you can bring this up uh
give
given
people i don't think people will
question me and this is a well-known
story he was stopped when he was coming
into the country with bodybuilding
magazines because of women and you know
bikinis and thongs and that was seen as
pornography
that was seen as free as you and johnny
cochran put it lascivious
outrageous uh so that was seen as
lascivious enough where it was a problem
yeah and
now we've obviously changed where
basically what would once be considered
hardcore pornography
is an advertisement for lingerie where
you can just walk into the mall or on a
billboard for
you know once upon a time american
apparel and i don't want to see
that eroding of the standard with
children
i don't want people to go like you see
with that slate article going oh this is
from
q anon uh faux outrage reactionaries
from the right
you know what a nine-year-old girl
rubbing her reproductive organs on
camera in cheeky shorts
yep i'm reactionary because if that's my
daughter i'm strangling
the director so i also have a pro i want
to look into what these i think these
parents like we can't believe that they
would subject them to that
but i don't want to see that ball get
moved
at all i think it's too far in the fact
that this film was released
in any capacity so i want to be crystal
clear about this
when we talk about protecting the most
vulnerable among us and this is true
with the left they don't believe that
they always end up victimizing the most
vulnerable among us let's look at kovid
we are taking the exact wrong tack with
covet if we want to protect old people
what are we doing we're locking
everybody down so that at some point it
doesn't stop the virus when we go back
out
old people will be just as at risk and
more of them will die granted in between
now and then if we're in states where
governor whitmer or cuomo has sent young
people into nursing homes
but the exact wrong strategy to protect
the most vulnerable among us the sick
and the old what should we do
we should go on with our lives and
society and help
older people and sick people stay home
but because we need a political
grandstand because we need to go out
there with the optics and say hey look
we flattened the curve
we're going to put older people at risk
right now when we talk about women of
color
right women of color me too well we are
doing the exact wrong
thing when you demonize officers who are
responding to
calls of either serial rapists or sexual
abusers
or people like we talked about today
lancaster currently with a knife abusing
this woman
when a woman of color calls two three
times in a row and the police officers
defend that woman who can't defend
herself by force
using force and then you say we need to
defund the police so what are we doing
we are putting people
in minority communities most at risk to
that policy
same thing right now when we're looking
at children when we talk about
pornography laws
and we talk about artistic license well
you know what conservatives this is the
problem is when you don't teach sex ed
guess what they go out and
all of a sudden they they're like a kid
in a candy shop well you know what maybe
once upon a time that was a valid
argument but now you have
kids twerking and humping couches
at nine years old and you're
distributing it
to people who could be god knows how old
on the world's biggest multimedia
platform
and the media doesn't make you answer
for it at all this false culture of
victimhood
always always creates more real victims
or at the very least
ends up damaging those who live in a
real
victimhood realm more than you could
possibly imagine you think this is going
to help
kids oh kids can't go back to school
even though they're almost entirely
immune to covet hey
how do you feel about humping that bosu
ball
and if they really were trying to do a
critique they did a bad job of it but
big biggest reason is they forgot to
critique during the film uh
journalists like like scott cause that
would be seen as sexually repressing
young women they can't do it they can't
they can't say young women shouldn't
twerk on couches
young girls we shouldn't be simulating
young girl breasts they can't because
they've demonized anyone who exactly
believes in any sort of modesty is
sexually repressed what i was saying
like scott
mendelsohn from forbes he's the film
writer journalist there
he said everybody just go watch it go
watch it you're talking about it before
you watched it i don't need to watch it
to know that it's child porn i saw the
poster that's enough he said everybody
just go watch it and joe biden said hey
shut up i'm watching cuties so yeah so
one thing one thing i definitely want to
say
is that regardless of whether or not the
actual images turn out to be of adults
versus minors
or whether or not you know cheeky pants
or sexual
sexually suggestive dancing actually
crosses the existing
specific statutes that we have right
remember civil case here's a statute
criminal case it's even higher right
for a reason because you're putting
people in jail and you're endangering
their lives once you once they have
committed a crime and they're convicted
but we what we can't do and what
certainly there's no question that the
left is knowingly doing
is saying no no no no no no no they
didn't go
that far it's not actually child porn
while ignoring the entirety of the
of the part that is undisputed is that
you have put
hundreds of young ladies through these
auditions
ultimately focusing on four or five i
think it's four or five that are
actually in the film
itself focusing on them and their sexual
suggestiveness
just you know you've been involved in
media for a long time we're involved
here as well
the amount of time that has to go into
filming something and producing it
how many takes were done how many times
were folks just like hey let's just hang
out we're just going to take some photos
back here
no big deal and this is where it comes
to the issue of the entire industry
itself
and focusing on it not not saying
anything about the protections that are
being needed for children
why do you think kevin spacey got away
with what he was able to do yeah
why do you think why do you think uh
harvey weinstein was able to get away
with that
grooming yeah this is what it is it's
normalizing the type of
it's the industry where they have
protection rife with accusations
absolutely
by the way this is not something that
you could see happen anywhere else in
the country
go to any any tierra girl
talent show whatever they call them
beauty beauty pageants tierra pageants
whatever they call them
and see if you find anything even
remotely similar to this you can go
anywhere in the country
and nowhere will you have an entire room
full of people
where he would screen cuties and not get
a complaint that's also what's concerned
is this was given an award at a festival
it went through the production process
the green light process
the distribution process at netflix even
after the poster created backlash and
they changed it there wasn't anyone in
all of netflix this is so
commonplace in the entertainment
industry that all of them said ah you
know what
people just think this is going to be
something it isn't once they see that
it's just
girls and booty shorts and sports bras
and simulated 11 year old breasts
twerking
grinding their privates on each other
they're not gonna have a problem with
this no one there said oh
wait objection that's what's so
concerning do not
send your children into this industry
parents that's also an important message
here yeah they chew them up
and spit them out they eat them alive
what we've seen is enough it's
unacceptable i don't want that line to
be moved and it needs to be moved
back all right we are going to have to
go exclusively here to the uh
mug club for those who are not yet
members lot of credit.com club 69
for students veterans active military
we're going to do a whole other 45
minutes in a row
right now teach the hodgkin's jiu jitsu
and read your chat but youtube you must
i pooped piss off